so like you mentioned something earlier
just off the cuff but you were just like
yeah so i quit college in 2005. because
marshall's a thing yeah what yeah so so
you quit in college in 2005 to do
youtube yeah
wow yeah
okay
yeah
i said it a little wrong so i went i
went to two full semesters so i think it
was technically 2006 right and i was
signing up for classes
and
i was thinking about the amount of time
because the classes obviously get harder
the further along you get with your
um
with your degree yeah um because they
start dialing into the actual difficult
things and i was like okay i could be
doing all these extremely difficult
things for this yeah or
um you know which is now taking my time
away from this other thing that is now
starting to build that this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity yeah to
um
i felt like i was almost like the master
of my own fate with this world well i
felt like uh getting a college degree
while obviously super helpful for most
people
i i felt like this is something i can
always come back to yeah and also this
kind of puts me in a position where
i'm kind of like
following a system that other people
have put in place for me i felt like i
was making up my own rules
so did you like foresee
the [ __ ] ecosystem youtube would
become or you're just like no no
i'm like
i see it all you were confident
no
don't just have this like because
obviously how many videos or like how
where were you at at that point when you
decided to go to college yeah what kind
of stage was it i think we had
how many
i think we had six videos out
never do what i do unless your parents
are very well off and they're totally
fine with you not doing go like how they
want to help you how many subs did you
have when you quit the subs were not a
thing
they were called followers and
they were not a thing but the the reason
that i felt confident is because this
outside company that was competing with
youtube called
it does not exist anymore yeah they
reached out to us and they were like uh
they gave us this contract that was in
hindsight very shitty but
we were college kids who were still
living under our parents roof and we
were like you know what this makes sense
we could fund
these things that we love doing like we
just had the best time hanging out and
just laughing our ass off creating
things and like yeah
college because that's what the college
kids really want to do most of the time
the homework man you get one paycheck
you're like i am set for life
mother i have a career now
so so we signed a two-year contract with
this outside company yeah uh they they
offered us 3 600 bucks
to split between us for two years for
for two years each no no each month okay
okay oh okay
i know i know i know
it sounded worse it's still not great
though
uh so we each got 1800 bucks and we each
also invested our own money from that
yeah into the videos themselves and they
also give us a little bonus at the
beginning so i got to like i just piece
a [ __ ] car so i and like i couldn't do
anything because every time i got my car
it was like not where anyway so i bought
a new car and i was like you know what
this like we have a two-year contract
here we're pretty safe i could come back
to do these classes if i if i really
that makes way more sense yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it was like one of the one of the first
deals where a company was like trying to
compete with youtube and yeah
and uh part of their contract was uh you
this video has to be exclusive to us for
two weeks
and after the two-week period uh you can
release it to youtube but it has to have
a brought to you
tag on the front and at the end and a
watermark on it so so we like generous
so they even let you do that
it was but their their whole uh strategy
for marketing was that
they were trying to steal the audience
from youtube right yeah yeah yeah so the
only way for them to get an audience on
their platform was to let people know
but unfortunately they didn't have
anything to offer yeah that was out that
was bigger than the scope of what
youtube had to offer yeah yeah i don't
need to get into the legality behind it
but eventually we were able to get out
of that contract because they promised
us a certain wow i don't know if i
should have said that company name
you want to bleep it out
rudon
thank you bleep out of the company name
uh
so now i feel more
i feel comfortable saying everything
um
so
they promised a certain amount of
marketing value and they they translated
that to a certain amount of views it was
like some odd millions of views they
were promising to bring to our videos on
our channel on their platform okay they
did not live up to that and uh when we
started getting on them about that we
found out
i'm wondering how much i should say this
is how many years ago now jesus is 16
years ago jesus uh maybe it's okay i
think that there everyone there is
probably um in a different i don't know
buried underground yeah um
uh so they
they what i realized they started doing
to to fulfill their end of the bargain
right was um well first i noticed that
we oh we had a million new views on our
video on this channel this day
okay so this this website where our view
videos usually get five thousand views
are now getting a million five thousand
views right there's something up here
so
oh
so so i go i go into the comments and
uh i get um
who [ __ ] smosh what is this [ __ ] i'm
trying to look at my mp3s and this is uh
why is this play i i find out that they
also own this other website and they
have a little
hidden iframe
uh that's like auto playing our videos
in the background of this other website
oh [ __ ] so they'd go
go to this website and then they'd hear
the audio of our videos while they're
trying to [ __ ] browse this other
website and it would count as a view
oh my god so eventually we were able to
get all the contracts we were like this
is not very cool it's actually giving us
a bad reputation because people think
that we are doing it yeah yeah and then
eventually we were able to get out of
that and it was at that time that uh
both
oh my god myspace was trying to
launch
launch a video platform i'm not sure if
kids today know one of my favorites no
no it's it's your space
uh so they were trying to launch a video
platform and they came to us with a with
an offer and then youtube
uh was like hey we're gonna there's this
program where you can make uh money on
your videos on our platform that never
had any ads before would you like to be
one of the first 10 channels to
ever make any money on here we'll give
you a guarantee and even though their
guarantee was lower than myspace thank
everything in the world we said uh yeah
we'll stick with youtube yeah yeah and
that's kind of where everything started
that was early 2007. that's when
was that just like were you just just
guessing or did you genuinely feel like
i think youtube's gonna be the king
there was this
feeling also we had a video on their
pokemon theme song lip sync video
yeah
it's like the godfather
you know you go on like the imdp uh the
imdb page of like youtube videos
uh
so that video i think had something like
25 million views
jesus christ and
it was easy to see that the the market
the the viewership was on youtube and
they had just been purchased by google
for
you know way too cheap
yeah and which is still billions of
dollars
and
i felt really good about google i felt
good about where they're going even
though i met tom from myspace you know
myself i was like um google you've been
the creator of myspace yeah yeah briefly
uh he was just a dude i mean i don't
know a dude wearing a nice jacket
he did not i feel like everything within
him was like i i can't do that i can't
even give a thumbs up or smile
no no he was he was a good guy
did he add you in my space um was it we
were already friends bro
yeah but was he in your top eight
friends that's the real question he
became part of my top eight after i
thought i might have a deal with him
i'm like [ __ ] if he's going
i think he's photography now and he's a
good photographer but anyway yeah um
so i i went with youtube we went with
youtube ian and i made the decision to
go with
youtube there and obviously was the
right choice yeah it just felt right you
know yeah yeah right so you were getting
paid even before there was even like an
economy on youtube yeah yeah you know
the funny part is that the all they were
was the lower third ad the little tiny
thing that pops up at like 15
seconds
and even then
you know we were afraid of
the backlash that we might get for
that's so funny so
yeah
we enabled it on our older videos and
then the newest video we'd wait until
like our audience bigger audience came
in and left so that we wouldn't get
flack for it and even on our older
videos people were like whoa are you
[ __ ] so loud
it's an ad where you go your mouse
everyone no one's on mobile you're on
your computer yeah all you have to do is
move your mouse and click the x and
people like
[ __ ] this there's one extra step
now people watch videos and there's a
minute and a half unskippable ads
in the video like whenever youtube gets
sponsored they're like yes king make
that money yeah yeah but no did you get
like backlash when you had your first
sponsor because i i feel like i feel
like everybody's wondering i think yeah
oh you mean smoothie king was that what
it's not your first one it's the first
one it's called smoothie king who's this
like i don't know if they're independent
or if they're like a chain but they're a
smoothie place in like austin texas or i
forget somewhere in texas i don't know
and uh yeah we just had to make a little
video there and put it up we didn't even
put on our main channels our second
channel yeah they paid us like a couple
thousand or something and it was it was
like you know what that was the
reception to that though um what the
[ __ ] is is this
but early youtube she's so wild
there were absolutely
no rules and i remember when i first
started i would actually uh go out of my
way to break rules to show youtube that
this rule could be broken oh i'm just a
bad boy
one thing that i realized is that there
was this channel that
um i can't remember what the name it was
in fact it's probably better that i
don't say that yeah yeah they
they they had videos that would just pop
off but they'd have like 12 comments and
i was like
this this math doesn't add up yeah and
of course as an 18 year old kid i was
like i must get down to the bottom of
yeah it's my duty
incident detective mode yeah yeah yeah
so
i did a test on our myspace and
um it was it was kind of what i learned
from that other company doing the hidden
iframe thing
so i realize on on myspace you can hide
an iframe as well right which is
ridiculous i think that anyone could
have any page load in the background
yeah so i hid it on our page and um
i realized that that worked so i said
youtube um fix this i don't draw it i
don't know if they if it was even me
saying it but also a big thing was that
that channel was also having
hundreds of thousands of new subscribers
i think it was right when they announced
subscribing right yeah
and uh i was like how is this channel
that gets so little comments having so
many views and subscribers so i also hid
an iframe on our channel that are on our
myspace that auto subscribed people to
our channel and after like a day i was
like yeah this is gross not gonna have
this on here so i removed it we got like
a hundred
200 new subscribers i felt gross about
it yeah and i think and you know in
order to repent for my sins i went to
youtube and i was like
this uh is a way that people are
cheating the system yeah right so then
youtube like within the next couple days
added uh on the subscribe page they had
a little button that said are you sure
you want to subscribe
back when you could actually talk to
youtube yeah
especially if you had a big audience on
youtube you had it was like concierge
service
you just kind of get [ __ ] done oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we went and hung out in um i don't know
i don't remember saying i don't know san
bruno san jose some some some sand
sandwiches near san francisco yeah and
um you know hung out with people there
that worked there wow chad hurley steve
chen the creators of youtube yeah dude
um you don't have enough subscribers
yeah
look at the good old days right yeah it
was so rare though for people to have an
audience because most people that
uploaded videos
we're one-off viral clips so it was very
rare for people to have audiences and
have recurring
you know videos of a specific channel so
i think that they really treated
everyone back then as like their gems
that were like keeping the channel or
like making
something bigger because i remember back
in the day it was just like you would go
on like the most viewed you go on like
the most viewed of all time and like
obviously the pokemon lip sync was there
evolution of dance [ __ ] charlie bit
my finger you know the classics yeah